hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday Morning
podcast strictly for the purpose of
checking in on
you seeing how your week is going oh
it's Thursday everybody
no matter how much you hate your job
it's [__] Thursday no matter how much
you wish you weren't there you just got
one more [__] day
one more day and then it's the weekend
oh it's the best Friday night
just decompressing
by going out
altering your mental state
and taking it out on an innocent
bystander
right
that's what the weekend's for everybody
unless you love your job
yeah
then I don't know what you do you go
home and do some needlepoint get eight
hours sleep
and all of that [__] you know what um
I'm coming to the end of my break here
as I have mentioned as though Billy
freckles has mentioned
uh it took me like [__] you know two
and a half months to learn how to relax
to just stay home today and just watch
basketball I'm just pick you know I'm
not [__] doing [__] today
I'm just gonna sit here because I can
because for the rest of the year I won't
be able to so I should just sit here
listen how aggressive I sound about
relaxing I'm gonna sit here because I
can't bill
sit here because I can
and I'm not going to give a [__] that my
heater is going to [__] make me feel
like I have malaria and then for some
reason rather than just letting it
naturally go from 71 degrees back down
to 69 it's going to crank the AC and
make it go down to [__] 61 degrees
and then it's going to [__] you know
go back to malaria
which is what's happening in his people
oh that's a common problem we can come
over and we can fix that and then they
come over and they air quote fix it and
then a few weeks goes by and then
there's the [__] problem again
this is my theory I think too many
people have solar panels and are
starting to get off the grid or use less
energy so now they're [__] rigging
these things for guys like me without
solar panels which probably surprises
you guys
that I would not have solar panels
considering
you know I am a Prius driving Hollywood
liberal
what else Trump supporter trying to
think of all the [__] things I've
been called
um
and no one seems to pick up that I don't
like any of you
yeah I haven't liked a president since
uh Jimmy Carter I keep saying that
speaking of solar panels
put them on the White House and then the
you know
it's funny how the right hates actors
unless they become Republicans
I loved [__] Reagan and
Schwarzenegger couldn't get enough of
those [__] Hollywood phonies right
not saying they're really phonies but
I'm just saying they were from Hollywood
and that's what they say they say that
they're phonies right everybody out here
is a phony oh it's so [__] Hollywood
I love when people do that they [__] on
Hollywood oh it's so [__] Hollywood
what isn't Holly
what is it you name me one [__]
corner of the earth that there isn't
somebody with power that people aren't
saying something to Holly the whole
[__] world is Hollywood from here all
the way to Vladimir Putin when he puts
on the [__] skates and all those
[__]
Russian [__] act like they can't stop
them
like they couldn't lay him out as he
skates across the [__] red line with
the puck with his [__] head down
you couldn't lay that guy and then he
takes a [__] shot and the goalie goes
one one thousand two one thousand
what about those [__] Ginger [__]
out there in South Carolina running that
[__] town and all the cops everybody
looking the other way it's all the same
it's all the same
you know what it is you're just too ugly
to be out here
kidding
I was always too ugly to be out here and
if I can [__] if I can carve out a
little Foxhole
of [__] joke
entertainment then God damn it so can
you come on out here you don't even need
to anymore right evidently that's what
all the kids say
you don't need to be out there man
hey you can make Gone With The Wind in
[__] Oklahoma
all right well go ahead and [__] do
it
actually what am I talking about I do
reservation dogs out in Oklahoma that's
a great show so once again
no need to email me I already know that
I'm full of [__]
um but what I wasn't full of [__] about
is I told you guys I was getting rid of
all my cigars and I look on the shelf
right now is barren
there's nothing there there's a couple
of Lighters left I got them out of my
house all right well I got them out of
my garage and now they're in my bedroom
I just need to bring them over to where
I'm going to bring them you know what's
funny is I did a benefit
on say
on Saturday night I did this benefit for
the troops right
and um
uh
as a thank you
they got me a box of [__] Cuban
cigars
and in back of my head I knew it was
coming I was going to say can you do me
a favor
you know I'm already having fun doing it
just
you know just don't give me cigars
because I'll [__] smoke them and then
they gave me
a box of 25.
and they're real
and what am I supposed to do now I'm
[__]
every time they you know pull me out
drag me back in I'm right back in but
um
I don't know I thought about smoking
them like 15 times today and I didn't
oh I could have I had the free time
I had the cutter I had the lighter I had
the scar
I had to get I had the [__] coffee I
had the whole [__] thing and I didn't
I didn't which is good I've had one
cigar this month and I'm [__] good
with that that's that's gonna be the new
me
the new me is gonna be I know I know you
guys like you're not gonna do this bill
well I'm gonna [__] try but I'm
getting all this [__] out of my house
and um
those but those cigars are just too nice
to give away I can't so I don't know
what to do so what now I'm gonna see is
how long I can make those last
can I make those last 25 months or I
just have like three four friends come
over and I only smoke one and they smoke
the other three
then I'm down to 21. see what they see
the problem here
um
anywho but that's that's my deal so
instead of smoking and being a [__]
idiot I uh I went and I played drums
instead
went played drums and I got
um
I don't know I got like this I got this
new thing like I'm trying to [__] sit
up straight and actually be on my sit
bones for the longest time I thought I
had like a sciatic nerve problem because
of all the years of sitting in cars and
on planes and all of that
and all I had was flesh and bone on my
backside because I didn't do enough
squats not [__] true it turns out
that I wasn't sitting down properly I
wasn't on my sit bones as they say let
me see here I'll go over sit down on my
sit bones you pick a hard surface and
it's the [__] you got one bone in
each butt cheek that's what you're
supposed to sit on and if you sit on
those [__] things rather than where I
was sitting I was sort of lean forward
and I was cutting off the circulation so
I would play drums in my one of my you
know one or both feet would start going
numb and I would be like oh my God am I
having a stroke what the [__] going on
here it just turned out I was not
sitting down properly so if you are a
drummer
or if you just work in an office and
your feet are going numb and stuff you
might want to check out your posture
and learn how to sit properly
which I'm still figuring out how to do
because now I sit down
on the drums in a k and not only
occasionally one starts to go numb and
then I just kind of kind of think as I'm
playing a song to kind of uh where's it
oh there it is I still like lean back
still lean back not like Fat Joe not in
a cool way I lean back in a bad posture
kind of way so
um you know that's where I'm at
I saw I literally so didn't do [__]
today that I forgot today was Thursday
and I had to do a podcast
and uh I gotta end this vacation though
because I'll tell you this right now I
used to never have a problem [__]
with these podcasts remembering when
they are talking about [__] but like
when you're just sitting around and
you're not doing [__] you run out of
[__] to talk about
you know like I'm literally gonna talk
about the weather
it has rained like a [__] out
here
and stupid ass L.A lets it all go down
most of it go right down the LA River
and out to the [__] ocean
um
it's [__] I don't understand I just
don't understand
here's a question for you guys why is
doing the right thing versus choosing
the money why is it never the same
or can you give me examples in your life
where choosing more money and doing
what's right was the same thing
you know
it always feels like choosing the money
is always a shortcut
you know you're going to feel dirty
afterwards but you got this bag of Loot
and you're gonna [__] you know and
I'm gonna go buy some stuff and it's
gonna make me follow more stuff that you
gotta help [__] me out whatever the
whatever it is
whatever this [__] was
you know
um
I'm really starting to get paranoid
about the whole the whole consumption
thing
that I bought into you know
like you know most people that I'm gonna
buy I'm gonna have stuff and it's gonna
[__] make me happy if I have this
stuff and everything and like I think
the most [__] up thing
the most [__] up kind of stuff is
disposable
you use it once and then you throw it
out
it's got to be this when we got away
from
like uh I feel like manufacturers
always resented repairmen
you know
or repair women or repair these
huh
I just want to make sure I'm on the
right side of history with this podcast
um
ugh
is there anything more painful than
listening to liberals say that I just
want to make sure I'm on the right side
of history now you don't you just want
to cover your ass that's what you want
to do and say that I made the effort to
say that word in that sentence and
therefore I can now just continue to
live my [__] stupid white life and
not take responsibility for anything
stop acting like you're a [__] hero
all of them and you know what's funny
about all of that [__] is then that
becomes a cool thing to say and then all
those [__] [__] say it and then when
the [__] hits the fan because somebody
makes fun of it they all [__] run
away and act like they didn't say it
you know
it's driving me up the [__] wall
you know listening to people saying like
can we no no comedian got canceled like
what are you talking about
they're like parents I never did that
never happened
nobody on a half-assed accusation lost a
year or two of their career
and has that controversy that [__]
on their [__] Wikipedia for the rest
of life that never happened yet did
yeah it did
just because you were doing it or didn't
fall into the group that was that was it
was happening to
you know that's that's how it like uh
remember
that's what people do when when the [__]
when it comes back around again they act
like I know what are you talking about
and I always I always equate it to
rollerblading that was the first fad
that I was into and I saw everybody else
was into it and I still loved it and
everybody else walked away from it
and you know and there was a whole that
homophobic joke was attached to it and
it made the whole thing go away
what's the hardest thing about
rollerblading telling your parents that
you're gay that joke happened right and
the [__]
1999 and a half right
and that was it for that fat and I was
really [__] upset I was like I like
this this [__] is fun I always wanted to
learn how to skate I'm kind of learning
it on Rollerblades which I felt in some
ways was more difficult
definitely more cumbersome you felt like
you were in uh
you had wooden shoes on
um it still didn't help skating or
whatever I mean maybe use some of the
muscles maybe it helps your breath but
it didn't it didn't help the skating but
like I've just sort of noticed that and
everybody
like you literally see somebody that you
rollerbladed with would be telling that
joke and you just looking at them like
you know we rollerbladed together
right
do you remember Central Park holding
hands
that was you right I don't know what
you're talking about
um only Gabe yeah us we were we were
part of that yes we were we might as
well had [__] rainbow shorts on
um
I still stand by it I still think
rollerblading is cool
um
I do find it amazing you know that that
scooter somehow
that fad
survived any sort of like homophobic
joke or something maybe because it
became motorized
you know but I kind of look at that like
like Gary Hart
had an extramarital affair and that
ended his presidential campaign in 88
and then in 92 Clinton had like 50 of
those
and he was just like ah you know I like
[__]
and then he became president like four
years later
I feel like scooters are the Bill
Clinton of fads and rollerblading is
like Gary Hart for some reason you know
one thing you do have to watch out for I
will say is the uh year nine of a decade
and if you feel like you're doing
something that's really popular if
you're a part of it like this next
decade next decade is going to be rough
like the first time I saw it was with
disco was cruising right along and all
of a sudden It Was 1980
and it was like [__] you man New Wave AC
DC Back in Black as far as like white
music went you know
just commented on that right and then it
became all these metal bands and that
was all [__] fine to like 89.90 the
odometer flipped
right then all of a sudden you know
Allison Chains was sort of the first one
like 88 let you know that [__] was gonna
change and then [__] uh Jane's
Addiction ritual came out and then never
mind 91 and it was like that was it
they were that was the first time I
experienced the whole fad and saw the
whole [__] thing go away
and
overnight
it felt like
like where did Motley Crue with all
these [__] where did all my bands go
who are who why is everybody dressed
like Roseanne
on her show everybody had like [__]
flannels on and all of that
um
anyway in 99
what went away the.com and rollerblades
I might be a little off on this all
right
2008 2009 what went away
the ability for somebody making thirty
dollars a year to get a mortgage on a
three hundred thousand dollar house
what happened in 2019 uh uh the ability
to go outside
went away right in the 2020 okay
everybody inside
so what do you guys think is going to
happen in 2029
um
shout out to all the doctors though I'll
keep saying that all the doctors that
have been working on viruses my entire
[__] life and diseases shout out to
that thankless [__] job
um
you know as liberals and conservatives
and everybody in between that rides on
the same boat as you do just pokes holes
in the bottom of it with no background
whatsoever
foreign
it was one of the more fascinating
things I'm glad that uh
it was I don't know as frustrating as it
was at times
and bored as you got and all the money
you lost and all that it wasn't you know
you gotta admit if we could just all set
aside our difference it was a pretty
[__] Wild Thing
to go through
and uh I'm gonna go on a limb and say
none of us handled it that well
I know I didn't
there's a lot of screaming and yelling
but everybody's gonna every you watch
everybody rewrite history the other side
and we would have solved it no
now
no there was one group of people that
could solve it and they were getting
heckled the entire time
how come you can't you can't solve it in
a year
in a year as they quietly walked down
AIDS over 40 [__] years Geniuses
[__] changes this and what do I do I
sit here talking to myself
talking to myself on into a microphone
that's what the [__] I do
well nameless people sit with lab coats
working with germs
I mean it's it's pretty
It's [__] amazing
I want to talk to him like what is it
what's it like to be that smart
and then just you know
in between getting to work
and talking to somebody else that's
smart what's it like to run into
somebody like me
does your soul like does a part of your
soul float away whenever you run into
somebody like me and I just say you know
what I think that's what I think no this
is what they're doing
um
I've tried to be a little more
even-and-handed or whatever but I swear
to if you go back in the history of this
podcast I mean I I
I would I I was on board if you had a
conspiracy send it my way I am on
[__] bored
and uh I went all the way into that and
then I hung out with those people I was
like wait these people are out of their
[__] minds too and then I realized I
was out of my mind and then I was like
is everybody out of their mind
and I was like you know I'm gonna make
my life small
I'm gonna stay in my own lane I like
cigar do you like coffee and old trucks
that's what I talk about
um when I'm not pontificating about [__]
Beyond me right
I believe I'll call Vladimir Putin
Hollywood earlier in this podcast
whatever what are you gonna do
I have a mouth I use it I'm not paying
attention to it any more than you are I
hope
are you on your last set at the gym huh
what are you doing shoulders
you work in the upper body I call those
ego days
you know what I mean when you're doing
the [__]
oh wow that's an interesting question I
bet gay guys do more legs than [__]
straight guys
you know what I mean because we're
walking around urge [__]
you know
because I feel like chicks are always
checking out your arms and your chest
but if you're gay are gay guys more
looking at your ass and thighs there's a
question
there's one I just figured I'd throw out
do you guys do more squats see I asked
the difficult questions
foreign
with that
with this whimper of intellect let's
[__] let's do a little uh let's do
some ad reads here
everyone as I try to sit in the chair
and not have one of my feet go numb the
[__] happens to you in life
uh This Old House was something
something all right
oh wow you know just thinking like
plastic surgery is that like like
redoing a house
there's a lot of people doing that now
you know flippant except they're doing
it with their body
it's funny though but they they really
do it like plastic surgery is really
like flipping a house where you're just
doing the exterior but you're not really
[__] with the plumbing of the
electrical
that's the [__] you know that's the
thing that they're working towards
I would think is eternal life
and can you imagine
I mean it's not going to happen for us
the regulus
but those other people the people behind
the people oh boy I got the tinfoil hat
coming down off the bookshelf the people
behind the [__] people
like you explained to me how Dick Cheney
is still alive
I mean back in the day I mean one other
thing another tip of the cap to doctors
right and I'm not wishing death on Dick
Cheney I'm just saying that that guy
had major major [__] heart issues
that would have would have killed a
hundred shoe salesmen a week back in the
day and he's still walking around
you know pheasant hunting
does he have a fake heart I don't even
know if he does you know what's amazing
about that is you know what's great
about having a fake heart is when you
shoot a friend of yours in the face that
doesn't skip a beat
it just keeps coming along he was almost
emotionless I wasn't there I don't know
what I'm talking about um all right
Helix sleep everybody
Helix sleep is a premium mattress brand
that provides tailored mattresses based
on your unique sleep preferences the
Helix lineup includes 14 unique
mattresses including a collection of
luxury models
yeah they got a little pinstripe down
the side a mattress for Big and Tall
sleepers and even a mattress made just
for kids ages 3 to 12. so how will you
know which Helix mattress works best for
you and your body we'll take the Helix
sleep quiz and find your perfect
mattress in under two minutes come on
people
I mean you're going to spend a third of
your life in bed can't you give yourself
two minutes
to let them know how big your feet are
how much how much your ankles weigh
Helix knows that there's no better way
to test out a new mattress than by
[__] on it no Then by sleeping on it
in your own home that's why they offer a
hundred night trial and a 10 to 15 year
warranty to try out your new Helix
mattress 10 to 15 years depending on how
big and tall you are
now let's ask you know
it'd be funny if they look up to see if
you [__] need Viagra or not
you know if you're young and you still
got a nice [__] dick that stands at
attention just going to be pounding away
I think you get 10.
right if you like getting a double
double animal style you probably get 10
but you know if you're vegan
you know
I think you can get the 15. you get the
15-year one I don't know how it works
out anyway all I know is everybody is
unique
doesn't mean you're interesting
um it's just we can recognize that
you're not somebody that you're claiming
to be and everyone sleeps differently
that's why Helix has several different
mattress models to choose from
each designed for specific sleep
positions and field preferences you know
it says several different models
mattress models in the future I bet
Helix is going to offer an actual robot
model that you can bang on your perfect
mattress you probably go to their
virtual store
try out some virtual sex robots you know
and it's just like all right this is the
side of the mattress I want to sleep on
this is the side that I want to bang my
my my uh my robot sex doll on and then
they'll just they'll adjust it perfectly
I mean what I'm I'm giving them a
compliment saying that they're going to
adjust with the times
all right
you think the Hipster thing is going to
be is actually have a human partner at
some point you know they always think
everything back in the day was better
um
all right everybody's unique it's and
everyone sleeps differently that's why
Helix has several different mattress
models to choose from each design for
specific sleep positions and feel
preferences
it's kind of creeped me out here plus
Helix mattresses are American made that
[__]
air man
foreign
to 15 year warranty depending on the
model don't want to take my word for it
huh you [__] [__] Alex says
that last part wasn't part of the
part of the uh the dialogue here but you
know don't want to take my word for it
sounds very combative
for advertising
maybe I was a bad rate hey don't want to
take my word for it well Helix hasn't
yes you put your eyebrows up when you
read that one don't want to take my word
for it Helix has been awarded the number
one mattress picked by GQ and Wired
Magazine I always feel like sociopaths
read GQ don't they they're sort of the
male versions of women who read [__]
Cosmo
you know and stand in front of a mirror
and suck their cheeks in before they
start crying to themselves and then
going down
stairs
is everything all right honey
yeah everything's fine
well you don't look fine
Helix is offering up to 20 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners
go to helixsleep.com this is their best
offer yet and you know something that's
not going to last long
um
like an 18 year old prom night it's not
going to last
with Helix better sleep starts now
h-e-l-i-x all right there you go
all right 26 27 minutes and I can put my
feet up especially because my left
foot's starting to fall asleep you know
God help me if whoever [__] writes my
health insurance ever listens to this
they're just going to be adding
ex what do they call those pre-existing
conditions
well if you go back and you listen to
his podcast in March of 2023 you'll see
that this condition already existed
uh objection your honor uh my client uh
is a comedian and he exaggerates the
truth
uh him saying that his left foot was
going asleep
was a metaphor for how numbed up his
feelings were about life
uh sustained
okay well then we would argue that his
negative attitude towards his future is
uh gonna cause
they would somehow figure out a way not
to pay huh those [__] [__]
can you imagine what that must be well
can can somebody like who has that job
can you just cleanse your soul and write
into me
and just be like have you been in those
meetings
where they sit there and they try to
figure out
how they're not going to fulfill what
they promised to their policyholders
when they basically say like listen
we're in the business of collecting
premiums
not paying people in need that's just
what we told them
when the [__] hits the fan we have no
intention
of giving anybody even remotely
what was promised we're going to play
the blame game
and say it was an act of God or your
policy doesn't cover that and then the
genius part is
we're going to use all the money that we
collected in good faith
we're going to use a small portion of
that
to pay the legal fees to defeat all of
these
innocent people in court
that's the game plan
I just want to know when you when I know
there's a corporate way of saying that
without saying it
but I always wanted you guys literally
do the villain in a
B movie after that do you all go move
afterward
um
anyway I don't have any answers to
people
I don't have any answers all right other
podcasts have answers all I have is uh
theories
couple of questions and a foot that
won't stop going numb
get on your sit bones I'm on my sit
bones well you know it is this is sort
of a wicker chair how do you sit on your
sit bones
in a wicker chair that's like a Jeopardy
question
I am a kind of chair
that doesn't help if you're sitting on
your sit bones
Carol uh what is wicker
what is wicker what's the deal with
wicker all right that is the podcast
everybody uh good luck with your March
Madness brackets
I hope you get along with everybody that
you care about and I hope people you
don't care about you don't give a [__]
about and you let them
[__]
live their life away from you live that
life away from you
um that's it I don't know why I just
want a bucket of fried chicken right now
I have no idea why I was just thinking
what am I going to do when I get off
this podcast and am I bought it my my
brain just said why don't you go out and
get a bucket of chicken you know what's
funny too it was a no-name brand too
the Colonel's face was not on the side
it was just a white bucket that you
already saw the grease like clouds
forming on the outside of it and I was
going to sit there you know it's you
know what's the greatest thing about
eating a bucket of chicken is not eating
the chicken it's it's the way you hold
the bucket like a newborn baby
I don't think there is any other greasy
food that feels the level of affection
before it's consumed like a bucket of
fried chicken
all right
I have close friends in my life that I
have never held the way I've held a
bucket of chicken
um
all right can you tell that I've been
eating healthy like now I'm just like
these are all like Distant Memories and
[__] but like I'm kind of
I [__] up the other night you know or
the other day I went out and I got some
food for me and my wife and I got her a
little dessert and she's been being good
she goes yeah I don't want to eat that
and she was like if they now if they had
this other thing which they had and I
was like [__] I should have gotten to
that so then you know I was raised not
to waste food that was the excuse I used
and I consumed that and everything then
I got sugar back in me
so last night I'm getting ready to go to
bed
and I say uh
like hey Nia where's where's that box of
those uh plain M M's you know I had like
a movie size box of those things and I
[__] hate playing Eminem's there's
just something wrong about them too too
[__]
handfuls of them and the level of sugar
in your [__] body you're like what am
I doing like am I gonna am I gonna come
back from this
and you still finish the Box
and it's like you feel like you're in a
contest like you should get a [__]
tea like you just literally can't stop
and my wife goes
she goes you don't want to do that
you don't want to do that come on you're
doing so well you don't want to do that
I was like yeah
all right I went downstairs
I got a glass of water
I got my wits about me and I came back
upstairs and I was like Hey Nia and
she's like well I go thanks for that
you know that goes on Hill Street Blues
hey everybody
be careful out there it was the exact
same delivery and I think I [__]
crushed it
um
all right that's it
oh yeah okay wait wait
I don't have anything to do I'll keep
talking you know what else I like I
always liked when McDonald's had the
double cheeseburger they used to have it
and then they would make it go away
you know
like they deliberately made it rare and
when it would come back I my favorite
part Beyond consuming it
and ordering two in a large fry
when I was a little kid I would get a
chocolate shake but as I got older and
more mature I went with the [__] Coke
you know what I mean not because I
didn't want the chocolate shake because
I wasn't secure enough in my manhood at
that point to drink a chocolate shake
in front of my drunk friends
you know
would it be great if you had the [__]
Poise of a 54 year old
at 14. can you imagine if he just a 15
can you imagine
this this but there are kids out there
like that
and they're all out there one of you
know
they're out there banging teachers
[Music]
yeah this is what happens you just keep
talking you just say stupid [__] all
right so my favorite part
is uh
they should do that in one of those
[__] trials where like some
female like I swear to God anytime
there's a female teacher banging a male
student like I'm always jealous
I'm always just like you I mean I'm not
a hater I'm like good for you good for
you
oh my God
can you imagine doing that you can't
[__] tell anybody because you're
gonna hear me that what a [__] that is
that is a [__] ride
um
as long as she doesn't convince you to
go out and kill her [__] husband like
that one did or something like that I
can't remember it's one of them you know
what's funny all of those [__]
Murder She Wrote in first 48s and all
that [__] that my lovely wife watches
right before I always fall asleep to
them and then they just all blend
together
in just one big Cesspool of [__] of
stuff that people like who would never
commit a crime and they just [__] do
it you know all of a sudden just the
right circumstances
you know like everybody they look at a
murderer they're like how could you take
the life of somebody else it's like well
maybe you know you never got to bang
your language teacher
maybe that's all you needed to be thrown
into the pot that was the missing
ingredient
you know
and then you take somebody out with a
[__] rake whatever the hell you could
find it's a murder weapon
um I'm a big believer in using a
non-murder weapon as a murder weapon so
then it can like hide in plain sight
when when the uh was it ballistic
forensics comes over
you know what I mean like if you beat
somebody to death little rake well it
would make all these [__]
first of all it's one of those wooden
ones like how many times you'd have to
hit them and then the [__] rake would
be all [__] up
that's not bad you're kind of destroying
evidence
yeah wooden rake would be good because
then when you're buried in the ground
it's going to naturally decompose faster
than an iron rake
but if you kill somebody with that iron
right that's more metal isn't it I kind
of grew up on that [__]
um all right that's the podcast
everybody
um did I even say why I like the double
cheeseburger I love the unwrapping of it
like I can still I can still I can still
hear the the sound of the paper
when it like I would unwrap
you know in that Rush
of pink slime trans fat just coursing
through your [__] veins
you know
after about seven or eight [__]
Michelob lights
maybe that's why my foot's going numb
um
Glory Days they'll pass you by all right
uh that's the park that's the Thursday
afternoon just for a Friday my mom uh
and please enjoy the the music
uh
um put together by the birthday boy
Andrew femalis it's his birthday week
baby
um please wish him a happy birthday one
of the great people
I've met in this business
um truly truly a great person and then
we have a bonus episode of the Thursday
uh afternoon just before Friday Monday
Morning podcast A Greatest Hits one that
you can enjoy that is it I hope you
enjoyed this while you sat in traffic or
sat on an airplane whatever the [__] you
did I hope I got you through
simple maybe listen to it at work we're
supposed to be working good for you good
for you [__] them right yeah [__] them
[__] them all right
[Music]
hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's the Monday Morning podcast for
Monday March
um what is it March 16th March March
16th
2015. how's it going I'm kind of under
the gun here I am uh trying to do this
podcast as quickly as I can I have a
weird
travel week where right now it's Sunday
night and or Sunday afternoon
and I am doing my final two shows
at the punch line in Atlanta ever
it's one of my favorite stand-up comedy
clubs
that I ever got to work at I absolutely
love this place I started talking about
it last week
but
um
basically I don't know what happened
they lost their lease I guess they're
redoing the building or some [__] like
that so now they have to move it it's
literally a stand-up comedy Museum and
uh they were nice enough to ask me if I
wanted to do one more night and that's
what I'm doing
and as you can hear my voice is much
better it's a little [__] up but I'm
doing much better
better and uh oh Billy freckles all
Billy freckles is back in the gym
um I'll talk about that in a second but
I do have to Hype something I have a
movie coming out this week
sorry a few more cops here
um a movie that a buddy of mine Jordan
Rubin directed called zomb beavers
that's right zombie beavers you know one
of the uh the bucket listings you have
to check off as an actor at some point
you got to be in a movie about zombies I
mean that's just my own opinion I mean I
am just a comedian who tries to act
every once in a while but as far as I'm
concerned
you know there's a few bucket list
scenes you have to do right you got to
get interrogated at some point get
punched in the face and act like you
would actually wouldn't tell the people
[__] right you got to do that scene you
got to do the scene where you get chased
down the alley and you throw the trash
can down and the cop leaps over it and
you get to the chain link fence you
start right as you're halfway up they
grab you and they pull you back down you
got to do that one
um you got to get shot and killed which
I did
I got shot and killed in uh Stand Up
Guys got killed by Al Pacino huh doesn't
get any better than that so once you've
checked those off
there's only one thing left to do you
got to do a [__] zombie movie
you have to do a zombie movie as far as
I'm concerned all these [__] English
[__] who go over there and you know
what Oxford wherever the [__] they go to
learn how to act then they come over
here and they can do an accent like
they're from Rhode Island and everybody
gets all blown away [__] all those guys
unless and women unless they did a
zombie movie so anyways a buddy of mine
Jordan Rubin um who's making this movie
it's about zombie beavers beavers that
turn into zombies oh he's turning the
genre right on its ear obviously the
movie
um he's making fun of zombie movies and
it's obviously it's well aware how
ridiculous zombie beaver movies are
beavers that are zombies I should say so
please spare me the uh dude how much
money did you need that you took apart
in this [__] thing it's a fun ass
[__] movie
um I got to do one scene in it with the
buddy of mine um
and uh you probably won't recognize him
because he's got on a wig and a mustache
and uh without giving away too much I
think work without us the movie doesn't
work
okay and that might sound arrogant but
if you watch the storyline it doesn't
work so it comes out March 18th you know
go eat a pot cookie go down there go
check out zombie versus uh
um directed by a good friend of mine
Jordan Rubin who I actually uh when I
first came down in New York City I used
to do open mics and work at the Boston
comedy club and all that [__]
way back in the day me and him you know
used to perform in front of like [__]
eight people
around midnight or whatever so
um you know it's great to see him move
up the ranks he's now directing movies
and [__] like that and he said I got
this over the top crazy [__] movie uh
you got to come down and have fun it's a
one day thing and I'm not gonna lie to
you dude I had a great time so check it
out have a good time but please don't
[__] text me like I thought this
movie was Saving Private Ryan okay I
understand what it is
all right so spare me you're [__] uh
shaking my head tweets and you know your
whole I have the world figured out
[__] horseshit all right just have a
good time with it it is what it is
you know what I mean
um you know I was reading actually
reading an article uh on the way out
here that somebody sent to me where
Patton Oswald was getting interviewed in
some magazine that I guess he's had
issues with
and um
I almost [__] ate the magazine it was
so [__] frustrating listening to him
trying to convey
to the person writing it like it's just
this this [__] judging of stand-up
like well don't we have the right to say
our opinion about the joke
it's like you're not a [__] comedian
this [__] thing where it's like
these selfish [__] just sit in a
crowd
and listen to an hour's worth of stand
up where everything under the sun is
getting trashed and they're laughing
along with it and having a great time
and then all of a sudden one joke they
don't like and they're like wait a
minute
is he is he serious now does she really
mean that and just like that whole
philosophy like if you do like a rape
joke or something like that like that's
somehow gonna make somebody who wouldn't
have raped somebody then go out and rape
somebody you know what I mean I grew up
watching Richard Pryor I never freebased
I never shot a car and made the engine
block came out I didn't have the cops
come to my house all that I never lit
myself on fire
none of that I never went to Illegal
crap games
you know
I never even been to a whorehouse
hey I pick up my hookers on the street
okay
um you know what I mean just just
[__]
this stupid ass outrage about nothing
and meanwhile
meanwhile you got a group of people in
this country a small group of people in
this country that literally turned the
food supply into poison
which to me is the biggest terrorist act
against this country that I can think of
every day we're eating this [__] that's
going to give us [__] cancer
everybody
you know what I mean and these [__]
jerk-offs
are are breaking people's balls who are
out there oh no please don't die please
don't die is this thing dying on me here
hang on hang on is this the headphones
is it oh it's the headphones oh [__] I
thought my battery's dying that's
[__] hilarious right in the middle of
making a great point
so these guys are too busy you know
rather than
dealing with like real problems are
sitting there breaking Comics balls that
are on open mics [__] around
[__] around
ah Jesus it drives me up the [__]
wall so I was reading it because I have
tremendous amount of respect for Pat and
[__] you know he's one of the best in
the business and listening to this
[__] person going like well what
about this the fact that a comedian has
to debate stand-up comedian on an
eyeball to eyeball level with someone
who isn't a stand-up comic and they
literally think that the points that
they're making are just as legitimate as
the comedians is one of the most [__]
arrogant things
like look I know a little bit about cars
but I wouldn't sit there debating what's
a better design with a [__] mechanic
I guess mechanics don't design and they
fix them whoever the [__] fixes them but
right there there's my argument I don't
know enough about cars to go eyeball to
eyeball with somebody
Jesus
[__] Christ
what kills me is
the [__] that they're talking about
now in comedy clubs has been going on
for 40 [__] years in comedy clubs and
nothing bad ever happened
but now there's social media and
everybody has a [__] camera in a
goddamn opinion and now there's this
this running around like the [__] sky
is falling because you didn't like the
answer to knock knock who's there
it's [__] unbelievable these [__]
like I don't know who that person is but
the level of jerk off that they are
arrogant [__] ass that they think
that they can just sit there and and
like they have this valid point
on setup and punch lines with a stand-up
comedian Jesus [__] Christ
I will never understand it
I will never understand people that
actually go to a comedy club and get
offended I just I don't understand it
and and if you get offended that's tough
[__] okay you went out to a comedy club
all right that's too [__] bad
that's on you all right I'm gonna say
this for the last time if you [__]
want to have a leg to stand on hire a
comedian for your own private party and
tell the person the parameters to
perform Within
all right other than that you don't have
a leg to stand on and these [__]
[__] on these stupid ass websites who
watch a clip of somebody performing in
the comedy club and they get mad at the
comic the comic is guilty of nothing
other than trying out material in a
comedy club if you want to get upset get
upset with the person who videotaped it
who was told not to and they're the ones
that uploaded it and brought it into
your [__] eggshell [__] world all
right
Jesus [__] Christ
Patton what about this I've never done
stand up is this a valid [__] point
Jesus Christ this is [__] the
arrogance of that
the [__] arrogance of it
unbelievable anyways well I [__] in a
crowd don't I have a everybody's so
[__] special now everybody's feelings
are so [__] goddamn special
grow a dick
okay
and let it slide off your [__] back
for Christ's sake and [__] move on to
the next joke you a bunch of babies what
a bunch of [__] I've never such a
[__] [__] time to be living in yet
some of the most psycho gangster [__] is
going down and nobody's [__] focusing
on it I like how gradually they're
actually talking about climate you know
that that could be the number one threat
against Americans is Miami is starting
to slip into the [__] ocean and
they're breaking somebody's [__]
balls
about a relationship joke that they told
in a strip mall in a [__] funny bone
that's getting more goddamn attention
anyways all right I'm off my [__]
soapbox sorry so anyways let's plow
ahead here uh this is one of my favorite
times of the year as far as uh this is
when like I watch hoop I don't watch
prohoop I watch college hoop and I don't
get into the whole [__] March Madness
the big dance I like the Regionals the
Big Ten Championship I'm watching right
now where Wisconsin was down by 11.
their biggest deficit of the season and
right now they got it tied up 67 up
you're probably asking yourself well who
you for here Bill I'm actually for
Wisconsin
I have some friends that went to to
University in Michigan so uh I think
Michigan State's more of an archrival
and uh I don't know
I'm kind of partial to all those [__]
States so
uh I like all those states that
everybody basically shits on I gotta be
honest with you or the part sections of
the country the flyover states the South
you know those some of those meth states
in the Pacific uh Northwest
I [__] love all those places
um and I plan you know what I'm I want
to do I got this Southern bus tour
coming up
which I'm so ridiculously excited about
I can't [__] wait
let's get on the bus with lawhead coach
and uh furzie
and uh
just go to you know a bunch of cities I
never I've never been to Knoxville
Tennessee
and it's gonna kill me that there's not
a [__] football game going on
um
but I blew through Memphis one time
really quickly I never been to
Shreveport I never I've never even done
stand up in Mississippi so uh to be 23
years into the business and to be
excited about coming out to all these
new places I can't [__] wait I got
this killer poster that uh
that I'm going to be uh whoring myself
out you know selling it at the end of uh
every show I'm going to autograph all of
them and um
I can't wait and I'm thinking about
doing another bus tour later on this
year where I go through uh
like you know Kansas Nebraska
Wyoming's the last state I need to
perform in so I got to do a gig out that
way go through Montana The Dakotas
um that whole [__] part of the uh the
country
um
I don't know good people good food I
like it
you know what I mean and I know whatever
some of the dumb [__] that people on the
coast give people [__] about in the in
the middle of the country like because
they know what's going on more in the
fashion world
there's different kinds of music or or
[__] whatever and like meanwhile like
the middle of the countries like our
food supply
you know
ah these [__] headphones are driving
me [__] nuts come on man
um
or like uh you know
you know all these morons who don't know
who the I don't know whatever you
consider uh you know they don't know
where to get good sushi but they can
[__] take apart a car and put it back
together better than when it came from
the factory I mean there's a lot of
[__] cool [__] out there I think
anyway so
um Beyond excited for that uh the first
week
uh the end of the tour we uh we end up
in New Orleans and we spend an extra day
in New Orleans which is going to be the
[__] and then the last uh the last night
of the tour we're going to be at the
Kentucky Derby so that's about as good
as it [__] gets so um tickets are on
sale for All Dates right now go to
billboard.com
and pick up a pair and we'll come down
and we'll give you we'll give you
[__] money's worth so anyways I
mentioned
that old Billy freckles was back in the
gym
and um
you know I don't know the holidays and
then I did that that [__] trip
through uh
you know Australia New Zealand New
Zealand and Southeast Asia uh
combination of that the Rose Bowl and
all that I became uh Billy fatiguan I
got up to like a buck 84. so [__]
pissed at myself man I was down to my
fighting weight 168 to 172. so this time
I've decided not only to get myself back
in shape I'm going to say what weight
I'm going to be
you know even though I'm not going to
[__] do some dumb [__] and stand on
the scale and show it to you guys but
just a mere fact that I'm going to be um
was this way too [__] quiet I'm such
a dumb [__] when it comes to this [__]
um
just to um
just so I'll [__] stick with it I
keep trying to get down to the last time
I had a flat [__] stomach and I had
ABS I was a buck 62. the closest I've
ever gotten was 167 but even then even
then I don't know how to do it right
I still had like the belly you know what
I mean because you start dieting you
actually end up losing muscle and that
type of [__] but I'm gonna try to figure
out how to do it without going to GNC
and getting that awful [__] cancerous
[__] whatever the [__] that's there's no
[__] way that stuff is good for you
that science that powdered [__] that the
FDA doesn't even have to look at to see
if it's bad for you
um someone's telling me all of that [__]
though those milks that are supposed to
build muscle so I don't get in trouble
um
yeah that they have like Metals in them
I don't know does other [__] have Metals
in it I have no [__] idea I don't
know I'm drinking a bottled water here
this was probably bottled like [__]
10 years ago
sat in a [__] Warehouse God knows
what the hell's in my system now but
anyways
just for the pure vanities uh
of it I want to see if I can get back
down there so uh I've been hitting the
[__] elliptical and uh I was doing
good man I got down to like a buck 78
but I [__] up last night because um
I made homemade ravioli
the first time I ever tried doing that
and I watched this video
and let these people put up
of their right off the boat Italian
grandmother and uh if you guys have
listened this podcast if you knew the
podcast I [__] love Italians
I love their country I love their food
I like their cars I like the flashy [__]
that they're into you know what I mean
um Virgie always says I'm a closet
[__] Italian so it's not enough for
me to go to Italy and eat the goddamn
food I got to figure out how to at least
make an attempt
at making it so um
you know I actually you know I got some
semolina right and I [__] uh did the
whole well thing
two eggs per pound I made a pound of
this [__] and um
my [__] the actual pasta part of it
the uh
the [__] um the ravioli part came out
great The Filling I had to Wing because
they didn't really say what the recipe
was so I kind of eyeballed it and I also
forgot to add an egg to it so uh it
tasted a little weird it was a little
too sweet had some sugar and a little
bit of cinnamon in it with some ricotta
cheese and right there you're like wow
that's [__] a weird
group of flavors there you got to make
sure everything's right and I tried to
eyeball it so um
but my big [__] thing is the ravioli
thing that I have I have like a tray
when you wait lay one sheet down and
then you put the filling in it in each
one of the things and then you lay
another one you do an egg wash and lay
another one on top then you get this
roller thing don't get those those
things [__] suck just get the stamp
because even after all that [__]
this is the second time I tried to make
it like 30 percent of them exploded and
all the filling came out anyways when I
was uh when I was in the midst of uh
trying to cook the [__] things but um
I don't know that's three hours of my
life I'll never get back
but I figure each time I do it I'll get
a little bit better
um
so whatever
what else am I doing here I'm sorry guys
this is all over the [__] map I
literally just landed and I gotta do a
show here they're picking me up in
[__] an hour so I gotta wrap this
thing up
and uh put on my my uh my stage makeup
before I get on uh I get on stage I
don't even know if they've even sent me
the [__] advertising have I got
anything meanwhile as I'm looking this
up how about those [__] Bruins huh
what do you think about them
um
those [__] were playing
mediocre all goddamn year and then
finally I don't know what's happened
like they had a nice little run there
right before the All-Star break and then
all of a sudden uh
you know they went right back to you
know win two lose two win one lose three
win two lose one that [__] and all
of a sudden they're playing
playing for their playoff lives uh beat
the Penguins who'd I see them beat
recently I've been all over the map I
know they'd be Detroit they'd be Philly
they beat the Penguins they beat Tampa
Bay
they're on a nice little run here
um
you know be nice if we could uh we got
swept by the Canadians this year but
it's just a you know it's just regular
season you get into the playoffs
anything can [__] happen and I still
think the uh Stanley Cup winner is going
to come out of the West
which means once again the Montreal
Canadiens will go home cupless
which really makes me [__] happy
I you know what I get so excited about
is that when they sweep Us in the
regular season I get I get text messages
from Montreal Canadian fans like they're
legitimately excited that they swept the
Bruins I mean it's a [__] compliment
back in the day they didn't give a [__]
they didn't win a cup it was a failure
now they're celebrating [__] that they
did in much
I just love
I just love that now there's that
there's actually 30 [__] teams you
know what I mean
all that [__] [__] goes out the
goddamn window you know when you're
competing with five other [__] teams
and you and you get first chance to sign
anybody within a 200 mile radius of your
goddamn City and you live in Montreal
yeah it's a bit of an advantage I'd say
I'm gonna go out on a limb and say
you're gonna go on a little bit of a run
there
[__] Bruins
we had first dibs on the best player
from Vermont
[Laughter]
socket Rhode Island
um
anyways uh
plowing ahead here I might have to stop
this [__] podcast I haven't got any
my information here
if we want information
who are you the new number two who's
number one oh by the way if you don't
want to ruin that um
that [__] I was imitating last week
um about that rich guy that guy I never
knowingly lied
I never I never purposely knowingly
lied
um
there's some news about him
in the in the papers just please do not
look at it uh if you're watching that
series because uh it kind of ruins the
series
um one way or the other because it's
basically
you're trying to guess whether or not
this guy will ever get uh
I don't know brought to Justice
um
so there's some information there that
that I shouldn't have said that [__] now
people are going to look it up and just
[__] tweet it anyways there's such
[__] where the [__] is my God this is
the time when I usually do the
advertising
why
didn't you say they over does it over uh
I might have to do this in segments you
know what I'm just gonna act like I'm
I'm gonna I'll just say that I'm doing
advertising I'll edit in later okay we
will be right back with the Monday
Morning podcast
after these messages
alrighty and we are back wasn't that a
great read that I did in the future
in the [__] future
I woke up this morning
and uh last night I had a 7 45 a.m
flight right
so my wife three pointer for Wisconsin
they're up 75-69 with two minutes to go
so I woke up last night I told my wife
that I had this 7 45 a.m flight she goes
you know what I'll give you a ride to
the airport and go all right you're a
sweetheart and then she mentioned that
there was the LA Marathon
and I was like well we'll get up early
we'll be fine but blah blah blah
so we go we wake up in the morning and
uh
we start driving down the street and
every [__] street is blocked off so
[Music]
um
ended up jumping on the highway
just cruising down to the LAX and she
kept bitching about the traffic she was
going to run into and I was going to
look at the other side of the [__]
highway there's nothing here
stop being
such a [__] you know what I mean you
know oh my God my life isn't perfectly
comfortable you know how women are right
the second the [__] AC is one degree
too [__] cold or it's too hot they
just start bitching
you know what I mean and for some reason
we don't just go ah just shut up
you know I don't know why we don't do
that why we don't do it more often
they're just [__] addicted to [__]
complaining so she's [__] moaning and
complaining right all this [__] crap
about the goddamn traffic meanwhile if
she had a 7 45 a.m flight I would have
[__] driven it and I wouldn't have
given a [__]
the granted I'm a morning person
he said to me she goes how the [__] are
you this awake she's one of those people
that hates getting up in the morning
she's like how the [__] are you this
week
and it's like well you know I had a
paper route from the time I was in third
grade I had a paper Road I never
knowingly
lied about sleeping in I had a paper
route from third grade until freshman
year or high school I kept that paper
route until freshman year of high school
to where it was like weird
like I was coming up like my voice had
changed and [__] I was still delivering
newspapers because it was considered a
little kid job
before the bankers completely [__]
over everybody and has everybody upside
down in the house and now it's like
actually an adult second job
delivering newspapers and um
I kept a job because I I liked having
money
like my whole life I had money like
if you had a paper route right in the
third grade like you had no overhead you
didn't have any rent
you didn't have any woman in your life
right
you couldn't drink you couldn't do drugs
it was just whatever you took home you
had
perfect
spending on football cards and
[__] candy it's all like it's the
only thing I could buy what else before
they're gonna buy sandwich I didn't give
a [__]
so I always had [__] money and I
always remember that like kids [__]
always bumming money off their parents
like when I got into junior high
I didn't I always had like an extra five
bucks on me which five bucks was like
having 50 bucks on you when you were in
the sixth grade
I mean lunches I swear to God were like
a dollar ten you can get doubles for
220.
I know I'm old go [__] yourself but
that's what it was it was like a dollar
fifty maybe for lunch something like it
was a dollar and change
so I remember that people be asking for
quarters and [__] like that I always I
always looked and I thought they were
pathetic
even back then I was like dude get a
[__] job
you're always bombing money off of your
parents but then I was jealous because
they got to sleep in on Saturdays and
Sundays and um
the paper that I delivered the Boston
Globe and the Boston Herald
came out seven days a week 365 days a
year I think I told this story before I
went from third grade
until sixth grade
um
before I finally uh had a day off
I did it every single day for like three
years and the only reason why I did was
because we finally took a family
vacation we were gone for a week and I
remember we let the uh
forget who we let do the paper routes I
think it was the newspaper company
themselves we let them do it and I came
back had all these [__] complaints
because it was some like [__] 27 28
year old guy
who's out getting [__] the night before
so he would just drive down the street
and just [__] throw him
you know with the rubber band around it
elastic whatever the [__] you say in
your part of the world just throw them
out the [__] window right into a
puddle or into a shrub and no one could
find it
and I remember coming back and everybody
bitching at me I mean I was terrible
myself I wasn't here last week I was you
know I was on vacation but my first one
in three years you [__] could you let me
in the house maybe I could warm up
do you notice my nostrils sticking
together every time I [__] inhale
that means it's cold out what is your
problem
what happened the one [__] week I was
on
156 week tear where you got it in your
[__] door dry every goddamn day seven
days of [__] week you're gonna break
my balls because I took a week off
right there right there that should have
been that should have let me know
they should have let me know what I was
in for
when you get when you get [__] older
just that constant there's always a
[__] problem
you know what I mean
and just somehow you just gotta like I
don't know
I don't know you know what if you guys
can figure out a [__] way
to to get a woman to sustain happiness
they can get it but to get him to
sustain it
just go for a nice three four day was
the last time your wife your girlfriend
three four day run was in a good mood
just cruising along letting [__] just ah
whatever don't worry about it it's all
good
I don't know how the [__] did I get on
this [__] tangent I apologize
I I never knowingly trashed women I
never knowingly lied about my
experiences with them Wisconsin's going
to win this [__] thing
Now They're Up by 10 [__] I'll tell you
basketball you know it it's a game of
runs
I saw this thing today where Yao Ming
Yao Ming is uh
he's like he's in China now and he has
this he has like a like a [__] I
don't know what he's doing he went to
some big Summit
in Beijing
right his poor [__] bastard the guy's
like nine feet tall
like his head is above the smog level in
that goddamn town and he's going in
there fighting the good fight for his
people right that's all I'm thinking
like wow what a great guy I mean this
guy's got all the money in the [__]
world
playing in the NBA he doesn't have to do
this and he's worried about his
countrymen and the guy's walking up the
steps right you can just see you know
[__] people like who are that tall
it's it's
they're never comfortable nothing's
built for their size
you know
they [__] you know the amount of work
their heart has to do to [__] their
hearts the same size as ours
that's why I don't see like a bunch of
eight seven foot you know seven year
olds the only guy you can think of is
Bill Russell everybody else like dies in
their 50s because your heart is the same
size as a guy like my size like 5 10 and
it's got to pump all that blood to your
tippy toes every [__] time it's a lot
of goddamn work right you got the RPMs
your red line in it there so here's the
guy walking up all these [__] stairs
eight foot tall dude
we're in some suit he doesn't have to be
there and you should see the picture
there's a bunch of people taking a
picture of the other guy it's like
[__] [__] leave him alone
he's going in there making sure the next
time you double Park you don't get run
over by a tank
right can you do the guy a solid and get
the [__] out of the way
I know is that weird is that weird for
me to say that
is it weird for me to be filibustering
on my own [__] podcast because I
still haven't got the questions or any
of that [__] for the week
ah Jesus Christ I'm about to send
another [__] text here by the way
I
you know I told you guys that I was
going to go out and buy a nice [__]
car I know what I'm getting
I know what I'm getting
um
oh there it is hey sorry about the delay
sending now was waiting on ads okay cool
um I know what the [__] I'm gonna get
and I'm not going to tell you guys you
don't rip it up I'm buying an old car
and uh
I'm gonna I'm buying an old car that's
gonna cost me about four grand
with a straight body
and then I'm going to get the [__]
interior done and the uh get it all
[__] painted right
and on top it's going to look like the
mid 60s when the car came out and
underneath is going to be [__] 2015.
just like those cars I see them making
on uh
on Fast and Loud
I watched that show so much
I [__] love that show
and
I basically I mean I'm trying to think
of a car I ever saw them make
I didn't like
I mean I love most of them but the worst
I ever had is I still liked it I still
appreciated what they did they just make
such great [__] cars and I got sucked
into that [__] and I was just sitting
there going like why go out and be
another douchebag driving one of these
all every [__] sedan looks like a
goddamn dinner roll now they all look
the exact same or I can go out like
Richard Rawlings does and find a [__]
car
you know granted I don't know how to do
it so I'll pay through the nose but I
don't give a [__] I'll find a car
that looks cool that has potential get
the [__] thing painted redo the
interior
like it just came off the factory then
underneath
you know
everything is [__]
2015.
2015 [__] technology that's one of
that's that's my game plan
and uh uh
I'll wait till the build starts going
and this one I'll actually show you
pictures of when I get this thing done
it's it's it's going to be a mean mean
looking [__] car unfortunately I have
weird taste in cars
I like to think it's original you know
every [__] jerk off baby boomer out
there wants a Shelby right they want a
GTO they want the [__] whatever
what is it that 67 Corvette tri-power
thing or the split window when everybody
wants the same [__] five cars and
meanwhile you got all these other badass
[__] cars that are just sitting there
um
Wisconsin wins
was that the Big Ten Champion
championship
yeah they got the hats on and everything
unless that's like an AFC Championship
hat I don't think it is no big ten
Champion congratulations
congratulations to the University of
Wisconsin for winning the Big Ten the
2014-2015 Big Ten basketball
championship at the NCAA division one
level and congratulations to stand-up
comedian an excellent fella all-around
fella Nate Craig who's from the great
state of Wisconsin who actually has has
me now
him and Jeff Cesario actually are two
comedians that I know that a big
Wisconsin Badger fans
so uh they actually got me into uh
Wisconsin plus the last time I toured
through
Wisconsin uh Nate worked with me and uh
he knew all the spots all the spots to
go and eat
all that [__] Dairy and [__] out
there
had a great goddamn time all right so
let's get let's get to some of the uh
let's get to some of the [__]
advertising [__] here come on man
this is well this is one of the problems
when you try to do a podcast and you
still have the iPhone 4S
what do you want from me I like old [__]
for the love of God for the love of
[__] God could you load could you
load just one [__] time
hey why do they block your internet at
the airport why do they do that
do they think I want to tweet that bad
that I'm going to sign up for the 20
minutes I'm sitting at the [__] gate
please tell me that's failing please
tell me that you as a person you know
draw the line there and you
categorically [__] refuse
to pay for internet at the [__]
at the [__] uh what do you call it
the airport right
all right what am I doing here
Lucy's kitchen what the [__] is that all
I was trying to figure out how long to
cook the raviolis for all right let's
see if I can get
to my goddamn emails for the week here
come on one time one time let's see it
work let's see it work and they are not
here all right
Jesus Christ you know what I feel like
right now I feel like I'm doing like a
Telethon and there's nobody watching
and I desperately need like callers to
be calling in so I can actually [__]
fill up this this this space here
anyways what's coming up March Madness
is coming up everybody The Madness of
March who do you like are you filling in
your brackets
why can't you just sit down and watch it
you know you know I'm really getting
sick of people that don't actually play
the [__] game getting this level of
involved like you play like be like a
fantasy GM
you know what I mean like dude you
should see my bracket I I picked all
they [__] you know what I want to see
I want to see you hit a [__] layup
I want to see you go out there and take
a jump you know what not even I want to
hello stupid ass [__] headphones keep
cutting out on me you know what I want
to see you do
I want to see you just run down the
[__] Hall just remotely in an
athletic way if you can do that then I
will take a look at your bracket there
really should be that you know what I
mean like when there's a sports bar
before you enter the sports bar they
should throw you a [__] you should
you get to pick your sport
football basketball baseball or hockey
you get to pick your sport and you get
three three tries
to hit the ball [__] throw a tight
spiral
go top shelf with the puck or a [__]
hit a free throw you got three [__]
tries if you can't do it that's it
you're not going in the bar
that's it then you got also got to do 20
push-ups if you can't do that you're not
allowed to
you know that's a great [__] idea
rather than do what you usually do when
you open a place is you let every
[__] animal on the planet
come into the [__] place what if you
actually had a sports bar and they ran
it like you know those dance clubs with
it with a with the ladies get all
[__] dolled up and try to go around
the line
you know
and they let them all in and there's a
guy you stand there like a jerk-off
that's Studio 54 [__] like if you have
the right outfit on you get to go in
what if they actually did that at a
sports bar
I think that would actually
if you actually had great food and great
booze but you did that on the outside
like all right dude here's the deal
you know if you've never been here
before we got too many unathletic
douchebags coming into this [__]
facility
all right we want people that are not
only sports fans but can actually play
the [__] game
all right
no [__] poses in here
so pick your poise
what do you want you want a puck you
want a basketball you want a football or
do you want to try to hit a [__]
slider
right and they literally throw you a
slider with a slider there you go
look at me I'm coming up with amazing
ideas that would not work because what
would end up happening is some fat
[__] blogger would go down there with
black swing glasses and the second they
found out that they couldn't go into
this place that they didn't really want
to go into to begin with
they would blog about it
and then they would be on TV going what
does this say what does it say about
Society of abundance is people
are you allowed to do that they do that
at um
at those dance clubs if you're not good
looking enough if you're not a hottie
they don't let you in
you know that never offended me
that never offended me I looked at that
the same [__] way I looked at some
classes that I was taking
just certain classes when you were going
through your educational system right
the educational system I should say you
just knew walking in you're like this
isn't me this isn't the right fit
I'm not going to get a good grade in
this and you just you just [__]
accepted it no you know I'm not good at
math you know I don't like English uh
history bores me and he just [__]
moved on why can't people do that at
clubs listen we're sorry
you're not good looking enough
buddy buddy you got too many chins what
do you want me to do you know get on the
[__] treadmill if you're gonna be
that fat you got to show up at least
with three [__] hot women
and even then you know we gotta kind of
stick you in the corner and make you
look like a bouncer all right we're
trying to make money here
this is how this works
right
I have no sympathy for people when they
[__] when it has to do with weight
and they say you're too heavy and then
people get mad it's like you know what
if you actually listen to them you'd
lose weight and you'd actually be doing
yourself a solid
these people in a roundabout way are
actually helping you to not have a
[__] heart attack have you ever
looked at it that way you selfish fat
[__]
um
all right here we go let's let's uh
let's read some questions here for the
week
um oh you know what wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute I gotta read uh let
me let me get the advertising out of the
way I'm not gonna drop it in where I
said I was going to drop it and [__]
that let me just blow through this Jesus
stumbled through those this week huh
all right let's get to the content here
before we wrap this [__] up
um all right by the way if you also if
you want to um
send an email to the podcast uh the
email is Bill at the mmpodcast.com
and if you'd like to follow me on
Twitter the Monday Morning podcast it's
at the mm podcast
that's our Twitter handle and uh if
you'd like to support
this podcast anytime you go to
amazon.com just go to billboard.com
first go to the merch page click on the
Amazon link it'll take you right there I
just get credit for driving traffic
there it doesn't cost you any more money
um I would really appreciate it we here
who never lie all right heat spell
um hey Billy sweet stack
I don't know what that means
um
no Billy's sweat stack
sweat stack stack of what sweat stack of
sweaty money
I don't know what the [__] that means my
balls on top of each other my Lane's
sideways on a couch it's the only sweat
stack I can think of um saw an L.A time
articles about how California has a year
of water left
if there wasn't a crazy breakdown of
society rather just a gradual Exodus of
California where would you go and how
long would you wait it out
um where would I go I go to Alabama
I go to Alabama man houses are cheap
you gotta deal with hurricanes but uh I
go to Alabama and I would either pick
the Crimson Tide or I'd pick Auburn
and I would just get involved in that
and then I would just be a comedian from
there or you know if the oceans are
truly Rising I guess I would move to uh
I don't know
maybe Tennessee I like the South
I'd move to like Western Tennessee
somewhere between Nashville and Memphis
I would live there get myself a spread
drive my old truck
and uh I don't know fly out to my gigs
I'd probably do that
um I don't think California only has a
year of water left
I think it's going to rain between now
and then
but we'll see who knows
I don't know what are you gonna do I
mean I'm in this business I have to be
in California I have to live on a fault
line and uh
I don't give a [__] where you live we
are going to be affected by global
warming and the end is going to come
uh there's too many [__] people we're
too goddamn selfish and it is our
destiny to destroy ourselves now having
said that go out there and have a good
time while it lasts that's how I look at
it isn't that uplifting well great all
right weight loss
um Billy Billy boy all right I've been
dying to email you for months but I
figured I'd wait
okay that doesn't make any sense okay I
lost weight my man and I got a
girlfriend out of it oh and I got a
girlfriend out of it I got a promotion
due to the extra confidence the the very
first podcast episode when you started
fat shaming I was all in I started
waking up early and running there you go
man there you go then about a week into
running I was listening to the podcast
during a run and you mentioned Cleo I
started thinking if I'm going to be up
early I might as well get that dog I
always wanted there you go and that's a
chick magnet right there I started
looking for a black lab but ended up
with a pit I named him Moby he's white
with brown spots oh Jesus [__] love
those dogs very rare have been told
anyways it looks like me if I worked out
and I was a pit bull right he's got
freckles there anyways I'm down to I'm
down 82 and a half pounds as of this
morning since October uh the first 20
fell off then it was just 10 a month uh
come back to Chicago loved hearing you
on the bar stool rundown thanks for the
honesty there you go buddy there you go
well you know what I let myself go a
little bit here so uh I'm trying to do
the same [__] thing it's kind of hard
when you travel so I just make sure I
eat right like um
I just walked over this whole strip mall
area and they got all you know they got
an Arby's I never eat at Arby's
something about fast food roast beef
always that's too adventurous for me
which is hilarious because I'll eat a
McDonald's and God knows what the [__]
that is
you know I don't know what it was my
whole life but I remember like 40 years
into me eating McDonald's all of a
sudden they had this advertising
campaign now a hundred percent real beef
and it's like whoa
what the [__] was it before right it's a
little unsettling
um that's awesome man and uh I fat chain
people to inspire in a silly way to try
to get you to [__] lose weight but
you really have to do you have to Fat
shame yourself if at some point you're
not disgusted with yourself
Like There's Hope in being disgusted
with yourself because you know you're
better than that all right what are you
doing right now are you sitting down
look down at your stomach come on man
you're better than that right you know
you are
you're better than that just you know
summertime's coming up get a jump on it
March
yeah you went in like a fat lamb go out
like a lion
I saw this chick the other day on Ellen
doing these pull-ups right and she said
don't worry about uh losing weight just
worry about getting strong first and
that's kind of like I was like you know
what I like that philosophy go to the
gym get stronger then all the other [__]
will hopefully fall into place that's
great man good for you 82 and a half and
you [__] pounds and that's six months
that's right through the holidays too
dude that's [__] hardcore and when
you only started dropping 10 instead of
20 you didn't quit like a [__] you kept
going so good for you man I'm psyched uh
your social life picked up too see that
he did it so can you
drop some weight get a dog and start
walking around smiling at people and
your life will change all right tux Bill
my girlfriend soon to be wife I hate the
word fiance yeah I hate that word too
it's way too fancy for what's going on
it's my fiance oh really welcome to
Applebee's
um and I worked my my soon-to-be wife
and I were talking and she said I would
I should own a tuxedo because I'll
always need one and it's better to have
my own that fits instead of getting
ripped off
with rentals every time
what are you a [__] senator
do you own your own business or you're
constantly entertaining people
uh he said I told her it was unnecessary
we both have great jobs but not enough
to buy a tux without thinking of reasons
why I shouldn't also Styles change I
told her and it'd be outdated do you own
it do you own a tux Nia sounds like she
knows a thing or two about style she
definitely does has she ever suggested
this to you thanks and come back to
Chicago
um no
now she hasn't I mean one of my [__]
James Bond
who needs who needs to own a tuxedo like
the the you know people who own tuxedos
like are doing something really
dishonest and they're constantly have
throwing these big [__] parties
because they know they're going to jail
soon so they're trying to bang as much
hot ass as they can they're trying to
get to know as many politicians and cops
as they can and judges to try to keep
their ass out of The Slammer other than
that no dude
buying a tuxedo is about as dumb as
buying a boat
you don't buy a boat you want a friend
who has a boat okay you don't need a
tuxedo you [__] rent one you rent one
and then you [__] give it back it's
over nobody gives a [__]
you know what I mean
I think anyways
I'm trying to think why you would own a
[__] tuxedo and you know I never even
thought
I never even thought for one second that
that
the style would change I'm trying to
think
the amount of times I've even worn a
tuxedo
I wore one at my senior prom
I think I wore one at a wedding where it
was a black tie event
um
or maybe it sat on the days at a roasted
back at the Friars Club and I had to
wear one I think maybe three times
three times in my life
I'm gonna be 47 in June
three times in my life have I ever worn
a tuxedo
um
look if you were [__] renting one
every month and it cost you a hundred
bucks then I get yeah I guess it's a
no-brainer you'd want to go out and buy
one
but what else is great you know as you
get older your weight fluctuates you go
up you go down you go up you go down
it's a [__] pain in the ass you're
gonna buy one in your 20s I mean it's
kind of a great way to stay in shape
that could be your [__] your
barometer could I still fit into my
tuxedo
[__]
God damn it honey stop making banana
bread
um all right sharks versus helicopters
dear Billy red tits all right that's
just mean
um they're Alabaster
um I
I guess certain fears are for certain
people I Surf and block out the fear of
sharks while you fly over sharks and
Surfers in a helicopter blocking out the
fear of flying the helicopter that's why
I am in the water and you are flying the
helicopter to me the helicopter would be
scary as [__] love you
um
it's scarier than [__] being eaten
alive by a [__] monster fish
let me ask you this
if you had to choose
between flying in a helicopter it loses
power and within [__] 10 seconds
you're like [__] slap or
being in the water having a shark come
up to you take a chunk out of your leg
to see what you are and see if you're
edible and as you're bleeding out the
[__] thing comes back and finishes
you off
I don't know man I'd rather get it all
done at once you know what I mean
you you'd rather have the window
shopping slow death I'd like to have it
done nice and uh nice and quick not to
mention
um
you know they train you in a helicopter
what to do if there's a problem
and you have an unbelievable amount of
[__] control
provided you react properly like when
the low RPM horn goes on you slam the
collective down
and you immediately start to auto rotate
you have an unbelievable amount
of control
um
in a helicopter
whereas with
surfing
I mean I don't know what are you
supposed to what are you supposed to
punch the shark and the nose and [__] I
don't know I'll take my but dude I
totally respect what you're doing
surfing looks fun as [__] and it has to
be funny [__] the fact that you would do
it in what in shark infested waters
which as far as I'm concerned is every
is the entire ocean because that's where
all the sharks are they're in the ocean
but they're not in this part really
that's interesting uh citizen four
uh Bill have you seen the documentary on
Edward Snowden no I haven't but I feel
really bad that I haven't kept up on
that because I feel like he did me a
solid where he was making this this
designing this this whatever the [__]
the computer word is for it to spy on me
and everybody else and he actually had
the spine to say I'm not going to help
you guys do this what I think he did was
really patriotic and nobody had his back
anyways he said it's really amazing I
tried to avoid it because I don't want
my blood pressure to spike getting mad
about the NSA uh nsa's practice
practices but it was great you can see
how calm and thoughtful Snowden is he
handled everything as well as he could
um citizen four is what it's called well
I will definitely watch that
um
as soon as I can
you guys should all go see that
watch it download it watch that so
that's your homework for the week watch
Citizen four trying to check out zomb
beavers if you can and uh I actually
watched an unbelievable movie last night
that starred Sam Rockwell who really is
one of the best actors of all [__]
time he's [__] unreal uh it's called
Moon check it out man really [__]
freak me out that movie
um all right well that's it people right
in an hour I apologize it's not a little
bit longer but um I'll be doing another
Thursday Monday Morning podcast whatever
the [__] you want to call it again this
week so uh I'll give you some added
comedy and some classic clips from the
old podcast and uh once again thanks
everybody for listening check out zombie
verse check out citizen four check out
Sam Rockwell in Moon